Now it's important to know that there are cultural restraints when it comes to
IQ testing. The question of race and IQ is very complicated and controversial.
Now we won't cover all the nuances of this argument, and the evidence
supporting it. But it's true that traditional IQ tests have worked against
people from lower socioeconomic backgrounds, because they're so verbally based.
And people from low socioeconomic backgrounds tend to be exposed to less
complex vocabulary. In order to be more culturally fair, non verbal
intelligence tests have been created. The most well known of these is Raven's
Progressive Matrix Test. This is what the test looks like. Because this simply
asks the person to recognize a pattern in shapes, it doesn't require special
language or educational skills. Hence, it's culturally free.